Jim, do you have an early
story of an experience
when you were first
starting out of having
to make sure that a
workplace was accessible?
I've had many.
I was born with spina
bifida, and I grew up
at a split-level house.
My parents never moved.
And I have really good
upper-body strength.
So I used to climb up and
down the stairs all the time,
and I did that until
I went off to college.
The wheelchair
was in the garage.
Which really prepared me
from entering, as Kaitlyn
and I also talk about, this
world that wasn't built for us.
And that is certainly
true in the theater.
For the summer theater
job that I wanted to get,
the booth was inaccessible.
It was up a flight of stairs.
And so I went down to Santa
Maria in central California,
and I climbed up
a flight of stairs
for them, for them to
see that I could do it.
And my solution that
whole summer was that --
I do have two wheelchairs.
If you're fortunate,
you have a backup chair,
and I had two push chairs.
And so I had one
left up at the top,
and I would just climb
up and down to get there.
I did a sound design for a
musical at the Public Theater
back in 1982, and I'd worked
with the director before,
and he wanted me there.
But I spent about an hour trying
to convince the production
manager that, physically,
I could do the job.
And indeed, at the
time, the Public Theater
was not accessible.
So I had to pull my
wheelchair up the steps
into the building every day.
I would also like to go back to
your example of being an intern
and bringing coffee, right?
So one of my first
days supervising on
set on a major
motion picture, that
was the job that I was given.
And I quickly
thought on the spot
of getting a crate
for the coffee.
I was responsible for getting
60 coffees during break
and getting it back there.
And luckily, we were shooting
at my alma mater, USC,
where I was very familiar
with the terrain, not
having a car of my own, and I
kind of just rolled everywhere.
And so I immediately called
up my barista, who knows me
by name, saying, hey,
so sorry, but can I
please put in this large order?
And they're like, oh,
yeah, no problem, right?
So I got the 60 coffees.
I got a crate, put all
the coffees in there,
called up another good friend
who has a coffee cart, brought
everything over.
So essentially, I was
able to complete that task
within about 15 minutes.
And I think this is
really just showing
we're just so used to
thinking outside the box,
because the world has
not been designed for us.
And we just have to do
that on a daily basis.
My supervisor at the
time was so impressed
that I was able to do that
that then he had to figure out
what other tasks to give me
to fill up my time that day,
and I was finally able to
do some VFX work, which
is kind of the whole
point of paying your dues
and bringing coffees and
getting the meals right,
and all that jazz.
In 2016, a friend of mine,
comedian, actor, disability
rights advocate, Danny Woodburn,
told me about a situation
that he became aware
of in New York.
There was a bill
that the state was
doing for writers in
television, television writers
and directors, to be more
inclusive, so that their tax
incentives would
include minority groups.
The problem Danny had with
it, and we all have with it,
is that it didn't
include disability.
And when he brought it up,
it wasn't ever addressed.
The law did pass.
And I think there's
something similar that
is in the works in California.
And as we all know, tax
incentives are a big deal.
As a producer--
that's why we shoot
in Georgia and other places
that have tax incentives.
This is kind of a
new issue that could
be really beneficial
for hiring of minorities
behind the camera.
Yes.
So for visual effects,
kind of like other aspects
of filmmaking, we're constantly
chasing tax incentives as well.
From my understanding,
any incentive
that comes from a
state should follow
state rules of hiring people
on a diverse spectrum.
And that, it does
include disability.
And I think tax incentives,
although it might be some --
you know, on the very top
of some people's lists.
But I think it just can be
added into a very long list
of benefits of hiring diverse
artists and diverse vendors.
For my company,
Alpha Studios, we
have been certified
as a disabled business
enterprise and
women-owned enterprise,
and we're in the
process of getting
the minority-owned business
enterprise as well.
And I was so glad to hear--
with all the chatters and
all the conversations that
we're having, and also just
riding the tides of this
moment, you know, with
Black Lives Matter --
that the minority certification,
they are busier than ever,
because they want to get ahead
of the wave of having minority
business certified,
so we can be in front
of the line for
these tax incentives.
I think that's just
one of many things
that are all slowly
helping us moving
towards a similar goal, which
is, there's lots of benefits
of hiring people that you might
not have worked with before.